[Music]
foreign
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Facebook when I start to see
Gary lineker says he has no regrets as
he demands as he demands for to be fired
reach fever pitch I think he has a right
to his opinion and I'll take on a
politician a sports journalist and a BBC
veteran who will vehemently disagree
olympica says the government's migrant
rhetoric sounds like Germany in the 30s
so is their language racist or was his
or debate
us Harry and mega may have given the
impression they want nothing to do with
the privilege to race its institution of
the prison cat monarchy but clearly
there's been a mistake because they've
just given Royal titles to their
children
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored good evening Fernando welcome
to Piers Morgan uncensored Gary denaker
and Jeremy Clarkson play for very
different teams one is a woke Warrior
who talks about football the other is a
curmudgeonly culture Warrior who talks
well mainly about cars and Farms one of
them invites me to dinner the other one
punches me in the face
Here We Go Again new season new titles
new managers new signings but apart from
that nothing much has really changed
off George Clooney
so yes Clarkson and Clinica could hardly
be more different what unites him is
they've both been the victims of witch
hunts in recent months for upsetting
supporters on the other side Jeremy
Clarkson made a crass hand-fisted joke
about his legitimate loathing for Meghan
Markle a tyrannical mob brandished
snitchforks and demanded that Amazon ITV
sever their ties with him maybe they'll
get their wish Gary lineker made pretty
exaggerated comparisons between the
government's migrant policy and Nazi
Germany a tyrannical mob descended to
demand he get fired by the BBC and they
may yet get their wish now many of the
people in the anti-clarkson model are
the very same people now defending
thenika many of the people in the
anti-lynnica mob were among the loudest
Defenders of Clarkson in this game of
two halves both sides are wrong the link
is standing by his right to an opinion
and today he faced down another mob out
of the press variety camped outside his
home
yes anything about the Tweet Gary sorry
what about sending the Tweet tool no do
you stand by what you said sorry do you
stand by what you said in your Tweet of
course
thank you all good for him clinical's
got to go to bow to a howling mop and
you've been abused by a hundred thousand
Real Madrid fans at the burnabout
Twitter probably isn't that intimidating
but the BBC's bureaucracy may be a
tougher opponent that's a special knack
for tying itself in knots operating with
a logic and efficiency of the Pollock
Bureau the BBC's new chairman for
example Richard Sharp donated 400 000
pounds to conservative party and was
recently revealed to have helped
facilitate an 800 000 pound loan for
Boris Johnson shortly before somebody
called Boris Johnson appointed him as
BBC chairman there's been no
consequences
but it bound Emily mate list for skewing
Dominic Cummings for breaking his own
lockdown laws and driving 30 miles to
test his eyesight the BBC is a taxpayer
funded by decree and BBC News must be
consummately impartial I get that but
let me because I'm a news journalist
it's not even a BBC employee nothing in
his contract says that he's not allowed
to comment about news he's a sports
presenter comments he makes on his own
Twitter account are not funded by the
license fee he's not a spokesman for the
BBC certainly not their news Division
and he didn't make those comments on a
BBC program you might disagree with him
that's you're right I disagree with some
of what he said you might even decide
that you're so Furious about his
opinions you don't want to watch much of
it anymore that's your right too but to
shame him vilify him and demand his head
on a platter because he shared an
honestly held opinion is surely wrong
Free Speech means hearing the opinions
you dislike as much as the ones you
support
well joining me now is a former BBC
Royal correspondent Michael Cole talk TV
presenter Richard Tice and BBC broadcast
and Sunday Times columnist Matthew said
all of whom are shared by one thing they
all completely disagree with me so this
is a unique playing field where it's
basically me up against a team who's
going to try and take me down I'm going
to be curious as to which one of them
might be the persuade you Michael let me
start with you you're a BBC man to your
bootstraps you work there several
decades
20 years right I so what do you what do
you think of this from a BBC perspective
I think that he has to be severely
reprimanded and I think the BBC needs to
seriously review his contract why
because he is the face of the BBC in a
very real way in exactly the same way
that when we were growing up Richard
dimbleby was also I'm sorry no dimbleby
was the face of BBC News very different
thing he was lilica has nothing to do
with the news division he's not even a
BBC employee no Richard dimbleby was he
was in fact that Panorama was current
affairs it wasn't news Well news and
current affairs yes but the bigger the
point is this
BBC sport is not Speaker's Corner we're
not waiting for a program called rant of
the day literally every Saturday night a
match of the day rant and express
strongly held opinions is literally the
speakers match of the day on sport yes
on sport so what's the difference what
the difference is that when you have the
responsibility
of that position getting 1.35 million
pounds of the tech of the license payers
money every year actually treat you for
what he does well maybe I think so see
well only because in the marketplace if
Gary lineker was available to anybody he
would earn a lot more money and actually
earns more money pro-rata for other
companies than just for the BBC well
indeed he works for them then I'm quite
sure he would have no difficulty at all
finding other employment
he would have the pleasure of being a
martyr and I'm quite sure he's one of
the best sports presenters in the world
he shouldn't be begrudged for the money
he earns Tim Davey is the fairly new
director general of the BBC and he said
very clearly at the outset that he
wanted to instill and insist upon
impartiality impartiality is the BBC's
unique calling card so that is what's
wrong trust around the world I get it so
can a sports presenter and a face of
sport like Gary deniker Express a
political opinion yes if he wants to
stand for Parliament or
so here's my follow-up when Gary lineker
launched this year's World Cup last
year's World Cup in Qatar wrong two he
did a two-minute monologue yes attacking
the humans rights record of the host
nation Qatar he was told to do that by
BBC management so BBC management decided
then that garage could be overtly
political in his opinions I think on the
BBC they were on the BBC at their
requests that's coming to you on the BBC
Michael yes that's right they were
covering their backs because they've
been so much about it in the paper they
said how could they have the bra snakes
turn around having ordered him to do
that and express a political opinion on
their main show of the year the World
Cup launch show how could they do that
and then turn around and say you can't
express legal opinion that's a matter
for BBC sport when you're when you're
watching a sports Personality you do not
expect a political opinions now Lord
Lord grade Michael grade who was 80
years Day by the way he was a great man
happy birthday one he when he was head
of Channel 4 he said the BBC is there to
keep the rest of us straight in other
words to set the standard and that
standard means impartiality on all the
important matters and that's it's a
unique quality I think it's not even
impartial about football well he just
saw him in his underpants having made a
bet on BBC about Leicester winning the
Premier League
the bottom line so come on you're the
politician yes and by the way you
profess to be the great standard bearer
of freezing he's not denying him his
right to his freeze Beyond him fight
wear it conflicts do you want him fired
we're at cornflakes peers is he's in
breach of the BBC code of conduct he's
not he is he's absolutely I've got it
here no it's unusual for you not to know
this I know the code of conduct right he
is in breach he's not allowed according
to this in any circumstances whether in
journalism or Finance anything you post
on social media from a personal or a BBC
account he's in breach of that no he's
in breach that applies to news No No
statement that applies to news and
currency
it's not in his contract I can tell you
I spoke to Gary this morning it is not
in his contract which may explain why
the BBC has been incapable so far of of
doing any disciplinary action he is a
freelance contractor that's irrelevance
nothing in his content about his tweets
he represents the BBC everybody knows
him as the one of the great faces of the
BBC yeah and yes he can have free speech
you can't do that at the BBC no that's
the difference why can't you because
that's that's what it is it's a taxpayer
statement to be clear should be clear
he's not in breach of his contract he's
in breach I'm telling you see God
telling you for a hundred hundred
percent fact he is not in breach of
anything in his country nothing in his
contract and he represents nothing in
Gary appears nothing in his job and I
think you are right there because you
wouldn't be saying it so definitely as
you are but it's a question of taste and
context and good judgment this was an
outrageous thing to say it was out
so let me stop you there we're going to
have a debate later in the program about
the content of what he said which I took
exception with I don't think there's any
parallel between 1930s German rhetoric
led by Adolf Hitler that's what happens
when somebody doesn't know anything
about politics
although there have been some leading
members of the Jewish Community who have
said similar things about this rhetoric
involving the small boat so he's not
alone and in fact I think he was
repeating what something he'd read from
a Leading Light of the Jewish community
so we'll come to that debate a little
later I want to bring you Matthew say
it's a Matthew say let me ask you this
you have presented programs and podcasts
for the BBC right
guilty that's correct but so you are a
BBC presenters you're a freelance like
linear right
yes yeah but
it's a quick checklist to establish your
credentials so you are you admit to
being someone who is regularly produced
and presented BBC programs and podcasts
yes
like many political journalists
dissembling Mr said I want you to answer
simple questions you have presented and
produced BBC programs and podcasts yes
I present a BBC podcast and I'm I'm
proud of the podcast and you're a
freelance but if I can yeah I'm going to
ask you the question in a minute the
fact this is a fact-checking uh exercise
uh and and you're a freelance like
linnegan you're not a BBC employee
that's correct right so how is it you're
allowed to be spewing all sorts of
political opinions all over Twitter
zahawi is sacked you said in 29th of
January this year but the corruption
goes wider and deeper
20th of November 2022 it's been a period
of hugely damaging contradictory
Economic Policy from a single party
trust trash Boris trash and brexit keeps
shape-shifting the most damning thing
Tory back benches have cheered and wave
papers through it no these are if you're
not a tour if you're not uh well if
you're if you're a Tory reading this you
would say that you're an
anti-conservative pundit using your
Twitter feed to express strongly held
opinions about government policies you
don't agree with and so I'm my question
I agree it's been a laborious Journey
what is the difference between you and
Gary lineker why do you feel he should
be censored and if he does it again be
fired which I think is your position but
you Matthew Saeed can continue
presenting programs for the BBC and
podcasts and spew away about politics
with no censorship or being fired or are
you offering to fire yourself live on
Piers Morgan uncensored no
may I respond you may now respond
thank you so I think the fundamental
distinction there are many uh political
journalists who I think are rightly
hired by the BBC to bring a trenchant
opinion uh to the airwaves and we are
sold and packaged as people who have
strong political opinions Michael's
distinction I think was the absolutely
critical one there are certain people
who are the voices the faces of the BBC
lineker is much more than a sports
journalist we can see this to a certain
extent by the fact that his comment on a
political policy of the day has become a
dominant story and the thing to bear in
mind is that part of his moral Authority
his cachet his cultural Kudos is because
of the relationship with the BBC the
platform that he has to speak to
millions of people not just on Match of
the day when England plays an
international competition he is the
person who is speaking and
editorializing for 20 sometimes more
million people and I think people who
are paying the license fee are entitled
to expect impartiality from people with
that status okay I sadly uh am a minnow
if you don't mind myself it appears if I
may ask if I may ask you a question you
may just to push you on your position
yeah I agreed with a very great deal of
what you said about free speech I think
there's a great deal of hypocrisy from
those who are criticizing limica now who
would be celebrating him if he had
praised government policy on Asylum but
let me ask you this imagine England are
playing Germany in the final of the
World Cup three o'clock in the afternoon
and people are looking at lineker's feed
because he is a BBC freelancer and half
an hour before kickoff he's not a news
journalist he's not a political
journalist but because of the
association with the BBC he chooses that
moment to make a comparison between the
government labor or conservative and the
Nazi party Are you seriously telling me
that the fact that he is a sports
journalist enables him to say what he
wishes via the BBC platform well my
response would be my original question
to you I don't see any ethical
distinction other than his Fame
which I don't think he should be blamed
for because that's because of his
success and his legacy is one of the
all-time great England Strikers I see no
ethical difference between him and You
and I by the way I like your stuff as
you know I've told you this before I
like your column apart from when you're
hammering me right
um and I like your I like your tweets
when you're not hammering me so to be
clear I I have no problem with what you
do I just see no distinction between a
freelancer like lineker and a freelancer
like you both presenting shows for the
BBC him with perhaps more success which
is why he gets more money and fame which
is not his fault and as a result you
think there's a distinction because it
saves you from having to be exposed to
the same argument and therefore get
censored and maybe fired which seems
very convenient so let's draw this but
you you have very cleverly not answered
the question that I asked you the the
funnel okay fair enough
to be fair I'll answer you're right I've
actually written a column in the sun
tonight in which I basically answered
this question my bigger problem with
lineker was nothing to do with the
tweets on his personal account which I
don't care about because I don't really
go to going in again for my political
opinions uh I I did object to his
monologue at the start of the Qatar
World Cup because I felt that was the
fusion of sport and we'll play a little
tip of it here there's a bit of that
monolith
ever since FIFA chose Qatar back in 2010
the smallest Nation to have hosted
football's greatest competition has
faced some big questions
from accusations of corruption in the
bidding process to the treatment of
Migrant workers who built the stadiums
where many lost their lives
homosexuality is illegal here
women's rights and freedom of expression
are in the spotlight
also the decision six years ago to
switch the world cup from Summer to
Winter
against that backdrop there's a
tournament to be played one that will be
watched and enjoyed around the world
stick to football say FIFA well we will
for a couple of minutes at least
now I had a problem with that because I
don't think that was appropriate and
I'll say why because there was no such
monologue at the Russia World Cup there
will be no such monologue at the start
of the one in America Canada and Mexico
I can bet my life on it Qatar was
singled out for the one and only
monologue even the China Olympics when
they did that the BBC they didn't do any
monologue about human rights and I felt
that was wrong and I said so at the time
and I've said so tonight in my column so
in answer to your point I would say if
it said on air I have a problem with it
if you said on a personal account and
he's a sports presenter I don't have a
problem with it that's where my line is
even if it was half an hour before 20
million people are going to tune in to a
map what I'm trying to get you to
acknowledge peers is the inextricable
link between lineker's moral Authority I
mean we would not be discussing any
other footballer making a claim about
politics I mean if others go to Gary
World Cup
that is conferred by the BBC yeah but I
don't go to Gary didn't give a moral
Authority for goodness sake any more
than he'd come to me for it would you
bring in his advice he's the face of the
BBC it's a taxpayer-funded impartial
Hugh Edwards who reads the news it makes
no difference together they're not no
they are they're absolutely in together
the editorial guidelines make that
Crystal Clear they're all in it together
you're drawing a distinction about his
contract that's irrelevant he's relevant
it's completely irrelevant he represents
it's actually it's the reason he's not
being censored he represents the BB
there is nothing in his contract or
obligations to the BBC prohibiting him
from tweeting this is why the BBC have
not punished it says he's got to apply
by the code this is about the BBC I
believe passionately
in free speech Nation just to speak
peace unto Nation all of you want
himself no it's about trust we're
talking about the BBC here and Gary
lineker but the BBC first the BBC was
built on trust it took decades around
the world and it can be lost very very
quickly and the most important part of
that trust is impartiality not
neutrality that's a completely different
thing but being impartial and if that is
undermined by episodes like this people
will just say well that's the BBC again
spouting off this way or that way
okay fine so are you shaftable with
Matthew sahib BBC presenter of a number
of programs and podcasts making
political points on Twitter yes or no I
agree yes you are well there he goes to
totally she's also brought it into
distribute sorry I'm sorry
are you comfortable with Matthew
he's also brought the organization into
distribute everybody's talking about it
and that's very bad luck only in
disrepute to those who don't agree with
him
here's the truth if Gary lineke came out
tomorrow and said you know what this
small boats policy is fantastic send
them all back home you would be straight
out there and go Knight turns for Gary
then again
because I've got integrity and he's
completely wrong and you're wrong three
one I think lennica's got a lot of
integrity and by the way he's a lot of
balls he stood by his stood by his
position today he was wrong they all
agree lineker has to go but Matthew say
he can carry on presenting BBC programs
because it's an experience
I think I've won my argument gentlemen
very much indeed well become two more
people know what their Royal cake can
eat it trashing the royal family every
occasion and then using the titles of
prince and princess for their children
will they be debating more laughable
hypocrisy there's stuff involving Harry
and Megan next
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no out with the people's Channel don't
worry every little helps for God's sake
is nothing original anymore it's finger
licking good I'm loving it look let's be
honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at 7
pm join me just do it well that one two
[Music]
thank you
well you may recall that Harry and Megan
the favorite friends of this show have
spent years trashing the Royals as a
bunch of cruel privileged races trapped
in a terrible prison of an institution
so imagine our surprise when a
spokesperson for the couple confirmed
via People magazine the Princess Lily
bet Diner had been christened why would
they use a title for their children that
represents an institution they loathe so
much well joining me now to discuss what
this is author and historian Tessa
Dunlop whether it's of the Daily Mirror
Russell Myers and Michael Cole's
remainder because of course he was the
BBC's voice of royalty for two decades
as he reminded us uh all right Russell
miles I don't get this no because I was
sure that they kept telling the world
how ghastly the monarchy is it's a
prison camp all the Royals want to get
away from it but they can't because
they're trapped in the world of titles
and privilege and now they want to give
their kids the titles of prince and
princess even though they don't live
anywhere near the royal family they
don't do any duties they have nothing to
deserve it they live in a mansion in
Montecito in California and use their
their own royal title to make loads of
money which may be declared to why they
want their kids to have them yeah I
think we're you pretty much summed it up
for a lot of people they're seeing this
hypocrisy being played out it's like a
soap opera isn't it that uh something
out of an EastEnders scripts and uh
Harry and Megan have made an awful lot
of money and an awful lot of noise over
the last couple of years by telling
everybody how awful the monarchy is and
the monarchy that they left behind
indeed Harry and Megan wanted a half in
half out model the queen said that they
couldn't and so yeah it's very very
surprising that they should uh they
should want this for you so surprised I
would say rank hypocrisy yet again
first time on the show agreeing with you
you wait he'll turn the screws in a
minute I would like to suggest
Harry and Megan it's a bit like
criticizing the police force I often
criticize the Met police my uncle was a
commissioner in the Met police doesn't
mean that I don't believe in having a
police force you can criticize the
monarchy and say here are the fault
lines and do it clums why would they
want why would they want to inflict on
their children Royal titles that make
them part of the royal family worldwide
and expose them to the misery and pain
and Trauma which Harry tells us he
suffers on an hourly basis normally for
large checks by the way because isn't it
very clear they've left the rigid
institution yes
and they're going and they've got
monarchy light Atlantic style that's
what they've done why do they want the
titles I understand
well a couple of reasons one is yeah
there's Cachet the pricelessness that's
cash yeah
and cash oh come on because we all know
Harry and Megan as Harry and Megan would
be making a lot less money if they
weren't the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
which goes on every statement they ever
made I just want to share something with
Michael and Russell and this is an
epiphany I had today when thinking about
pairs I do occasionally think about you
off screen oh but you never said I've
come to the conclusion that although you
sit there night after night professing
to be a monarchist you're not deep down
I am no because the whole point is with
the system of hereditary monarchy you
can't choose the loons and losers that
get born with the right to people no you
can't okay
it's all very odd it's pick and mix
isn't it we want the traffic yes we want
the it's raw cake we don't want the
juicy we don't want the hard work it's
this is all very very odd because
legally they became Archie and lilybear
became prince and princess at the moment
the Majesty the queen died on the 8th of
September and King Charles took over
because by the lattice patent drawn by
King George V in 1917 grandchildren of a
reigning monarch become automatically
Prince and this is what Meghan Markle
was struggling to remember in her Oprah
one of them when she claimed the only
reason she hadn't been already made of
Prince was because of his skin color it
turned out she just didn't understand
okay no I'm asking Michael because he
knows about these things of course about
how the system actually works there was
no racism no none at all and that was
actually quite shameful what was said at
that time
this is what she told 50 million people
around the world what did I do recall it
and regrets worth the idea of the first
member of color in this family not being
titled in the same way
that other grandchildren would be it's
not their right to take it away
it was a complete hang on Tessa it was a
complete lie appalling ignorance
appalling ignorance and also used in a
very very nasty way yeah attack people
who couldn't answer back yes and bring
them a bunch of races when they were
racism is a is a terrible accusation to
make because it's easy to make but once
thrown possible yeah Tessa you're
seething why I'm not seeing you've just
heard a lion
of the word
Michael I steamed former BBC journalist
80 years he's been walking on this
planet absorbing ideas of hereditary
monarchy in the British constitution
Megan you're not 80. on Monday I was
happy are you serious I'm sorry Michael
Cole you look unbelievable crazy really
yes well happy birthday very much
congratulations on being a new Lord
okay Russell let's bring this back to
the the ongoing thing is are they going
to come to the the coronation they threw
their little like spittle Omid scoby uh
he said that apparently they invited all
the Royals to uh lillibet's
um christening but they all declined to
come as if they're all going to get on a
planning fly to California to embrace
the people who've been trashing them for
the last three years but it looks like
from The Jungle drums they have been
invited yeah yeah to the coronation
right now they're holding it out to make
it all about them make it a big drama so
do you think they're actually going to
come uh I do now yeah I think because
it's their currency isn't it they've
made an awful lot of money and again
this uh it's they're attacked by by
having that Association right the royal
family Mr caching cash you mentioned
um the the favored journalists that they
were briefing in the in the first
instance that they weren't going to have
titles and now there's another screech
in U-turn we already had one of the
u-turns about the racism element within
the royal family that Prince William was
forced to
denying this is another example
is his majesty the King has played a
Blinder in all this because he led it
made it let it be known from the very
outset that they were welcome to come
Megan and Harry to the coronation
putting the ball firmly in their court
if they decline it will make them look
small-minded Petty mean-minded and if
they accept they will make them look
open the door to hypocrisy
in the tenth row right behind prince
Andrew so when the world's cameras get
beamed on them all they see is their
little heads bearing around
the King has spoken about unity and
togetherness so and I don't think you
would be as cherlish as to not invite
them I actually think you shouldn't have
invited why would you invite a couple of
rap bags you've been attacking every
member of your family because if I'm
just saying what I would have done if
that was people in my family I wouldn't
want them anywhere my coronation which
by the way can only be a matter of time
yeah but you make the point there all
you have to do is one of your Offspring
marry into the royal family and hey
Presto the Morgans get a little tingy
monarchy that is how unbelievably mad
the system of predatory Monarch is we
all get fat chewing the fat of this
story but the problem you have peers is
you like the system when it works but
you don't like it when it doesn't no no
no Harry is an example
you completely misrepresent what I think
about the molecule my mother camped on
the mouth of both Diana and Fergie's
weddings right we grew up we had we ran
a country Pub in East Sussex well I
remember this 1977 Silver Jubilee the
street parties and everything it was
fantastic so I grew up that's when it's
working hang on oh it wasn't working
even then right there's always been
chaos and Carnage in the royal family
you know when I was a newspaper editor
barely a week went by without some new
Scandal that's not the point the
distinction with these two is they have
openly attacked the institution of the
monarchy Diana didn't do that Fergie
didn't do that they have unloaded on the
institution being a prison camp that no
one can escape from why then would they
call their kids prince and princess I
was 10 at the last coronation you
haven't asked me to guess peers but I'm
going to guess what will happen
May the 6th is Archie's birthday yeah I
rather fancy that she will stay behind
and have a birthday party in California
and he will come particularly as three
days later he's due to be the star
witness in a very contentious case
that's going to be opened against mirror
group newspapers and he's going to go
into the witness box yeah that is going
to come after the Lord mayor show we
know what happens after the coronation
yeah we've got a court case no Harry as
we know is very concerned about privacy
uh on that bombshell on that bombshell
we'll leave it but yes it's going to be
an interesting month uh lovely to see
you Michael lovely to see you great to
see you pleasure thank you all very much
indeed we're coming up next go to liquor
accuses politicians of echoing the
language of Germany in the 30s Adolf
Hitler the Nazis that migration so have
their words gone too far or have his
we're going to debate that next
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no with the people's Channel don't worry
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it what that one too
[Music]
this is talk TV
well welcome back so away from whether
Gary Indiana should be sang from the BBC
and by the way I think he's going to be
at all there's been a huge backlash over
how he compared the government's
rhetoric on migrants to the rhetoric in
the 30s in Germany from Adolf Hitler and
the Nazis in his tweet suggested the
homose secretary's response to the small
boats crisis used quotes language that
is not dissimilar to that used by
Germany in the 30s well Jordan discusses
right from commentator Larissa Kennedy
and comedian Constantine kissing who
moved to newspaper in Russia when he's
11. I've still got Richard Tice here and
also Paula Roan Adrian is with me as
well so let me start with you uh Larissa
on this
when you read what gynenica said did you
think that was a fair analogy to
contrast this government with a regime
that was building in the 30s in Germany
which was to go on to slaughter 12
million people
to be absolutely clear what Gary lineker
said is that and I'm paraphrasing here
but the language used to justify what is
happening here with this bill with this
proposal from the government is akin to
language that was used in the 1930s in
Germany so I think it's it's really
difficult to begin then talking about
policies and actions because that is
something entirely different because I
think what Gary was trying to insinuate
is that we need to be cautious of the
slippery slope here which is well
documented which is that language and
the dehumanization that language can do
is very very powerful in leading down
that slippery slope well it is it is
right but it is but I would argue I'll
bring Constantine in here my issue with
this is you talk about slippery slope
the moment you get into 1930s Germany uh
you evoke memory of Adolf Hitler and the
Nazis and the Holocaust and 12 million
people being you know murdered
exterminated in concentration camps six
million Jews in concentration camps and
so on
I just think that is a slippery slope
and the moment to me anyone invokes that
in relation to a current government like
this conservative government to me
you're losing the argument you're using
an extremity of a debate which just
Bears no relation to reality
well right and I'm not particularly
easily offended so I'm not offended by
his comments but the problem we've got
here is not so much that he said
something silly or insensitive for me
the problem is it's completely
inaccurate tens of thousands of people
we're not trying to get into Germany on
small boats and that is I'm afraid the
real problem with this whole argument is
the people who want to demonize Britain
is This Racist hellhole can never seem
to explain why tens of thousands of
people like me want to come to this
country and settle here and some of them
do so illegally even by breaking the law
and putting themselves in danger which
is something actually I think we should
all be concerned about and should be
seeking to end yeah I mean my problem
Arissa with this Gary Gary doesn't have
a solution to one of the biggest
problems with the small boats at the
moment which is a third of the people
coming in on these small boats are young
perfectly healthy non-vulnerable
Albanian men who are being recruited
they suspect mainly for gangs and
already in the UK they're being brought
over by Criminal gangs they're spending
thousands of pounds to do it so they're
not short of a few quid but these aren't
the most vulnerable oppressed people
from war-torn countries they're coming
from a perfectly safe country and they
you they're abusing our system but I
don't see anything in Gary's statement
about that reality of the people coming
over on these small boats in large
numbers
to be really clear we are often talking
about people being trafficked here and
in fact by not being trafficking rights
people of their rights
there are people being trafficked to the
UK there are being people people
repeat the question and so you know
better than genocide watch you know
better let me repeat my question because
your rights organizations
let me repeat my question a third of the
000 or so people who came over last year
to the UK on small boats were Albanian
young men perfectly healthy not
vulnerable not oppressed people for more
torn countries that's a that's a fact a
statistical fact and when I saw that I
found that alarming that said to me the
system was being gained now there are
other people who are coming from
war-torn countries in fact Britain has
been leading the way in putting up
people from Ukraine from Afghanistan and
other genuine war-torn places that is a
different issue but what would you do
about all these young Albanian men
coming in who are not from more torn
countries and just want to come in
without doing it legally
what would I do well I don't think my
first action would be to strip all of
those all three-thirds of those groups
of their rights illegally by
contravening international law I don't
know how the the question is being
reversed rather than the government's
actions actually being interrogated
because at the moment we are
contravening international law in 1951
we signed up to the conventional
refugees saying that we would not uh you
know put extra pressure or you know
impose sanctions on those who came via
illegal entry we signed up to that as a
country so it's not for me to now sit
here and debate okay
this is a problem
I mean there certainly is going to be a
massive legal route about this but what
is your response to that
well this is exactly the problem and
this is nothing personal to Larissa but
the people who who pretend to care about
these people never seem to have a
solution to the problem and the reason
is they haven't thought about the issue
at all now look at the point you made
about people from Albania being uh
smuggled let's say that they are being
smuggled why are they being smuggled
into this country because we allow them
to be to be coming in here in these
small boats and we don't do anything to
prevent it from happening and we don't
do anything to disincentivize these
smuggling gangs from doing it right and
all we have to do by the way is declare
Albania a safe country so that no one
who comes here from Albania illegally is
entitled to Asylum it's not very
difficult if you actually care about the
issue and my biggest concern is someone
who like you is proud of Britain for
helping people who are coming from
genuine uh need is that if we continue
to make the British public feel like
they're being taken for a ride and of
course they're right to feel that way
once we spend seven million pounds a day
accommodating these people if we
continue down that path and eventually
people are going to get fed up and say
we don't want anyone coming in we don't
care about the circumstances and then
the very people that these woke lovies
like Gary lineker pretend to care about
are going to be the one that suffer in
the end I mean to be fair to gardenica
everyone shouted them well if you care
so much take one of them into your house
and he did he took in a young boy
Refugee and he did take care of him and
he's very proud of him and so he did
actually practice what he preached um
thank you both but that's not the
solution peers no no I totally agree and
I I've in my son column tonight I've
I've said where is the answer Gary and
secure's Dharma and others criticizing
the government where is your solution
because I don't see one and the problem
with allowing so many obvious economic
migrants to come in illegally is that
you are then taking attention and money
and resource away from the people who
really need it and that is what we
should be focused on as a country but
Larissa Constantine thank you both very
much indeed you've got to have a short
break coming going to bring in Isabella
shot familiar to this Parish I think
certainly to you Richard uh and we're
gonna pick up on that and also get uh
some reaction to well it's called
lockdown files she really is Miss
lockdown files now remember her new name
Isabel lockdown files we'll get a
reaction to that new nickname after the
break
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation
with the people's Channel no worries
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy
speechwriters here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it
[Music]
thank you
coming up on the talk the BBC throws its
weight behind Piers Morgan's favorite
BBC presenter as Government ministers
around his controversial migration
comments offensive well they are aren't
they sex education in schools are set
for an overhaul after lessons are
branded a catastrophe and Prince Harry
opens up about what gets him out of bed
in the morning resume stay tuned for
that and much more at nine o'clock
listening
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook and essential
with me or Richard uh it's obviously
talk to the international is about
overshot and totally contributed all her
own ages so we'll introduce you there as
Miss lockdown files I said I've called a
lot worse this week what do you have I
was going to ask you about that you've
been mercilessly Trashed by many people
in our rep in our profession of
Journalism a lot of it grotesquely
unfair in my opinion
how do you feel about it look I I think
it's fairly obvious what's going on here
I'm quite a divisive character I'm a I
was a brexiteer I'm still pro-brexit and
with this guy that actually alone would
be enough really
but it's been really bruising I suspect
yeah no I I've broken a number of really
big controversial stories this isn't my
first rodeo I've been through it before
um it's not nice but it was it should
never have been about me it isn't about
me it's not about Matt Hancock it's
about actually trying to make a
difference here and I think that it's
achieved that how have you felt Richard
as the other half watching all this uh
just appalled actually at the way that
the industry has behaved because it's
about how government completely misled
the people they haven't focused on that
at all they focused on the messenger and
yeah it's pretty rough seeing your other
half go through that level of abuse
completely unjustified and what one can
do about it and um look I think a lot of
it is jealousy a lot of these people
have never broken decent scoop in the
lives well let's be quite clear if any
of them had had it themselves they'd
have run every word and lauded you as a
journalistic genius and this comes back
to my initial point about the lineker
story is a lot of hypocrisy flies around
about all these things
um Paula well I'll ask you not about
that but I'm asking you just for your
reaction to this whole linica thing the
boats crisis the language use put it all
in context what's your overview about it
so to answer the question which was is
the language dangerous the answer is yes
it is we know it's dangerous because
we've seen the reaction from members of
the society we've we've seen a a hotel
and immigration hotel that was
firebombed we've seen marches on the
streets Etc we've seen what's happening
to stir what would you do to stop this
Surge and it's a surge it's gone from a
few thousand a year to 45 there may be
65 to 80 000 this year what would you do
to stop it well I'll tell you what I do
I do the two things that Rishi sunak is
doing tomorrow he's going to meet with
macron and he's going to try and get an
agreement that would mimic essentially
the agreement that we had before brexit
Richard the Dublin agreement it makes no
difference
is kind of slipped in in the back door
whilst we're focusing the boat people
and Gary lineker's tweet is that I would
extend the list of jobs that we need to
bring people in we know we've got 1.2
million jobs that are going at the
moment and Rishi sunak said today that
he was going to open up that list to
include construction work yeah but
here's my point here's my point to you I
have a view that we should remain a
humanitarian country at our heart right
there what we did with Ukrainian people
with Afghanistan people and others from
Wharton from Hong Kong for example what
we've done with all these people who've
been in real trouble in different
situations we've been very Humane and
very welcoming
but I agree with those who say that
there's something inherently wrong with
a system that allows 15 000 young
Albanian men from a safe country to pop
up on a dinghy and get access to the
country illegally when there are lots of
really desperate people trying to get in
here from war-torn countries and they're
going through a legal route I just don't
think it's right and fair I don't think
most people do and and and you're right
I mean nobody can deny that but what the
problem has become is that we are mixing
two very different people we're mixing
people who are migrating for work and we
are mixing people who are seeking Asylum
but the ones if I'm ready for work
should be doing so in a legal proper
manner and they're currently not that
there's a seriously I want to change the
topic I want to change to Michael Kane
hitting out at claims that the great
movie Zulu has provided inspiration for
possible terrorists the film will start
as a key text for white nationalists and
supremacist Richard he's called it the
biggest load of bull he's ever heard
which I completely concur not least
because my brother was a colonel in the
Royal Regiment of Wales as it was
originally another Royal Welsh and of
course they got seven Victoria crosses
of the 11 awarded for this extraordinary
Act of Valor by the uh the Allied Forces
as they were then against the the Zulus
an extraordinary active Valor about
invading another person's country I just
want to be clear that that's that's the
starting point that's that's true but
the point okay the point the reality of
the question is it's ball today she's
got nothing to do with nationalism it
was an extraordinary uh scene of Bravery
of Courage of making the right military
decisions at the right time I've been
there I've been in the building I've
seen it I've seen what happened the day
before at izan dwana when about 1200
British soldiers were killed because
their leaders and commanders made the
wrong decisions just at the wrong time
with catastrophic consequences so look
there are lots of lessons to be learned
from this also about invading other
people's countries
it's not a it's a film about what
happened on the day it's not about the
Rights and Wrongs of British colonialism
over the last 150 years but the point is
it's it's an incredible story of Valor
of Courage and the film represents that
it's one of the great movies of all time
yeah I love it I completely concur um
talking of unbelievable stories that's
obviously we're talking about
unbelievable stories of Valor and
courage have you got any more Scoops for
us from the the lockdown files
um I'm working on it you put your
glamorous head over the parapet to be
shot at by your Rivals
um is there more to come I think there's
at least another day or so of it but
look this is such a huge issue for so
many people the number of letters that
I've had in emails people stopping me
was really let's be clear absolutely
riveting to read right it just has I've
read it all just fascinating insight and
if they want to commit all their
thoughts to WhatsApp and one of them was
to then pass it to journalists well this
is what happens yeah you'll be less of a
journey
have you had any more any more
conversations with Mr Hancock
um no you have no no no no no I haven't
no contact at all I haven't and I'm
awaiting his legal letter yeah I mean
two chances of him suing you no chance
and Bob Charles if there was a Bob
Johnson that joke would have worked
anyway keep keep going and ignore all
the haters they're just jealous thank
you I've been there keep your head
proudly above the paraben and take it
off good to see you both that's it for
tonight uh whatever you're up to Keep It
Uncensored you hear me BBC
keep going Gary that's it from us good
night
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it